[Música]
pues todos los días compramos cosas y
compramos servicios y no nos damos
cuenta que también estamos comprando
como el día de hoy ideas y personas
y bueno no sé mucho acerca de lo
importante de ser mejores consumidores
que realizan el producto
[Música]
en cuanto ideas
sólo hacer uso de aquella es hacer
crecer
[Música]
en que cuando aprendes a venderte a ti
mismo eres capaz de cualquier cosa
importante que tenemos que saber es que
todos todos en esta vida somos
vendedores aunque no lo sepamos no
importa
[Música]
es muy importante que aprovechemos la
oportunidad de esta herramienta
a pláticas y justamente eso ustedes
pueden entender cómo esto puede hacer
que tomen mejores decisiones tengan
mucho mejores relaciones no solamente
abrazos con su familia y sus amigos
él
[Música]
no
y también lo importante
un valor proporcional
a nosotros mismos
pero
[Música]
es muy importante aprender
la esposa de él
la situación es lo mismo
y también importante está en valorar
quién eres
maravilloso
en este mundo tenemos algo maravilloso
[Música]
y muchas veces nosotros compramos por
comentarios y por juicios que otras
personas hacían y familia
en el ecuador
[Música]
si juzgamos a un test por su habilidad
de paraguas seguramente
yo creo que tiene muchísimo es cierto si
tú piensas que no estás en el ecosistema
de ecuador
mentiras relacionadas de verdades para
definirse a sí mismo
nosotros mismos el tiempo en realidad es
que nos comparamos y obviamente siempre
nos comparamos con personas que pensamos
porque son exitosas o al menos eso
parece
y es que tenemos nuestra propia visión
del éxito tenemos el éxito como un
cuento así que cuando se libere tiene
cuantos me gusta tiene dos millones
quinientos del éxito
pero tienes que conocer y tienes que
hacer
ustedes deberían hacer su propia
definición del éxito la importancia de
que aprendas a conocerte y es que de esa
manera te vas a poder comprar y cuando
tú aprendes a comprarte es cuando
aprendes a vender de tips y cuando
aprendes a vender a ti mismo aprendes a
no comprar cualquier cosa porque
recordemos que las opiniones los juicios
y cualquier comentario que cualquier
persona no
y cuando todo está seguro de quién eres
y de lo que buscas en la vida es mucho
más
quiero finalizar en una pequeña plática
con esta frase que dice te podrás
olvidar de los sueños
pero no se van a poder hablar de ti
todos tenemos algo que no resuena cuando
platicamos acerca de sueños acerca de
ser nosotros mismos se atienden pasa
esto chiquito a moverte a cambiar
[Música]
muchas gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]